[Music]
if you happen to wander into the Nevada
desert and stumbled upon the secret US
military base area 51
you'd quickly be arrested killed or
maybe even abducted by aliens but what
if you happen to organize 1 million
other people through social media to
storm area 51 I mean they can't stop us
all right or can they and if you did
manage to get into the base what would
you see
this is what if and here's what would
happen if 1 million people stormed area
51 if you haven't heard of it before
area 51 is a highly classified US
military base it's heavily rumored to
have secret military technology and
perhaps aliens for decades it's been the
source of conspiracy theories but now
you want to see if any of those theories
are true how do you get to area 51 it's
off-limits to visitors so it may not be
on your GPS but there are online guides
that you'll need to use the closest
airport is in Las Vegas from there
you'll have to rent a car and drive
through the Southern Nevada desert for
several hours keep in mind that there
are going to be 1 million other people
doing the same thing as you if you think
traffic in your city is bad just wait
till you see this
Nevada's most populated city Las Vegas
has less than 800,000 people living in
it in fact the entire state of Nevada
only has about 3 million people adding
another million people all at once would
seriously damage Nevada's infrastructure
the roads to get to area 51 aren't an
eight-lane highway instead they're small
two-lane roads and dirt trails if 1
million people decided to do this they
may not even make it to the military
instead they may get stuck in traffic or
get into an accident so much for seeing
any aliens but let's imagine that
everyone somehow makes it to the front
gates of the base now 1 million people
are ready to storm area51 what happens
next well you and your friends are
peaceful people so you wouldn't be
carrying any guns you're just simply
running into the base as soon as you
crossed the area 51 borders you'd
quickly be met by the bases private
security these people also known as camo
dudes have weapons in hand and patrol
the base 24/7 in white pickup trucks you
wouldn't be able to sneak up on any of
these guys as they surely know you're
coming and it wouldn't just be the
Private Security trying to stop you with
an event this big the whole world would
surely know and it would be impossible
to keep it a secret area 51 is a
detachment of Edwards Air Force Base
which is located in Southern California
thousands of active military members are
stationed at Edwards you can expect to
see them along with thousands of other
armed soldiers and police members they'd
have their guns tasers tanks and who
knows what else the Armed Forces would
try to keep casualties at a minimum but
they'd still be hitting everyone with
pepper spray and other non-lethal
weapons they'd still be determined to
keep what's inside area 51 a secret so
most likely the camo dudes and their
military counterparts would open fire on
the crowds and they're authorized to use
deadly force so don't be surprised if
they started firing bullets if you're
lucky enough not to get shot or pepper
sprayed you'd get arrested but what if
you somehow managed to sneak past all
the guards well despite this you still
wouldn't be at the actual area 51 base
at least not yet you'd have to find it
that's because the original area 51 base
occupies a space of 150 square
kilometers but the property surrounding
it is 1600 square kilometers it's
reported that the base is discrete with
blacked out windows and hardly any
visible lights from the outside you
could be walking around for hours before
you found it
but once you've reached area 51 what
would you see well we're not really sure
what's there which is what makes this so
exciting
crazy military technology UFOs or even
aliens could be lurking about proceed
with caution though as some suspect that
the base is heavily polluted from
decades of government experiments if
that's true just being in the base
without proper equipment could result in
you getting sick or dying so storming
area 51 probably isn't a good idea it
would most likely result with you
getting sick or arrested or dying sorry
you won't be getting a baby alien as a
souvenir gift the only way you'll
probably be able to see aliens is if
they come to us but that's a story for
another what if
you